the major winter storm described by
meteorologists as a bomb cyclone who's
blasting parts of the country's
midsection powerful winds combined with
snow are creating blizzard conditions in
Colorado the governor declared a state
of emergency an out-of-control car
killed a Colorado trooper helping a
stranded driver all or parts of six
states from Colorado to Minnesota are
under winter weather alerts this morning
Janet shamlian is in Denver with details
of this extreme weather Janet good
morning John good morning this storm hit
Denver with rare intensity take a look
at this car it was crushed by a large
tree during those hurricane-force winds
this morning thousands of people are
still traveling are still stranded here
rather as the Denver Airport closed all
of its runways for only the fourth time
ever a whiteout on Colorado roads and
interstates left traffic at a standstill
for hours on i-70 six the blizzard
whirled around cars winds pushed 18
wheelers around like toys
more than 125 crashes happened Wednesday
in Denver alone officials shut down
major interstates for drivers safety the
storm also slammed Nebraska hard drivers
struggled to dig out of deep snowdrifts
overnight a state trooper got stuck as
she tried to rescue a stranded driver
the same system swept through Texas with
winds topping 80 miles an hour a
frightening scene as those gusts flipped
this semi-truck on a highway and sent a
tree through these homes in Dallas in
New Mexico high winds blew freight cars
off their tracks back in Denver airport
workers passed out blankets to stranded
travelers forced to spend the night by
day's end more than 1300 flights were
canceled
right now all the flights aren't gonna
fly out so like Friday or Monday so what
are you doing here in the airport we're
just waiting to see what our options are
downed trees and power outages are the
big problem here this morning more than
100,000 people are still in the dark in
bitterly cold temperatures viana that
damage is horrific Janet thank you